[Music]
welcome
i'm brian laurie i'm a professor at
stanford university at the graduate
school of business
and this is the leadership for society
webinar series
focused on race and power today i'm
happy to have professor ian lopez
um ian hanni lopez who teaches race and
constitutional law
at the university of california berkeley
he is the author of dog whistle politics
how coded racial appeals have reinvented
racism and wrecked the middle class
which focuses on the long history of
politicians
exploitation of racial pandering in the
service of maintaining
arguably the economic order and he's
also the author of merge
left fusing race and class winning
elections and saving america
which explains how the political
manipulation of coded racism has evolved
in the trump era
and before we get started i'd like to
start today
in honor of martin luther king with a
quote from his last book
written the year before he was
assassinated the book is where do we go
from here
the quote is why does white america
delude itself
they believe that american society is
essentially hospitable to fair play
into steady growth toward racial harmony
but unfortunately this is a fantasy of
self-deception and comfortable vanity
as the nation passes from opposing
extremist behavior to the deeper
and more productive elements of equality
white america reaffirms its bonds to the
status quo
all right professor lopez i'm really
excited to have you and
maybe work to unpack a little bit of
that quote thanks for being here
yeah thank you so much for having me
professor lowry although
if it's okay with you perhaps i can just
call you brian you can call me ian i
think this is
that last four that's preferred much
preferred okay all right let's go that's
fantastic all right good so
so you know king is riding at a time
when the country's already um
not just the country um the country
outside the south
is moving into a mode of backlash
against civil rights so
through 1964 there was a perception that
civil rights meant
ending formal segregation in the south
and there was broad support for that and
if bull connors is the face of white
racism
then yeah that man is evil let's let's
get behind
uh taking away his power reforming
southern society
but by 67 it was clear that this would
require
substantive reform significant reforms
in the north as well and a backlash was
developing
the quote is also really relevant today
in
2021 because it's a quote that asks
us to think about whether white america
is really prepared for equality
and to think about the way in which
white america
is responding to movement toward
racial equality and i think that that
as we try and understand trumpism as we
try and understand the insurrection
the invasion of the riot in congress
um last week that's really a
very challenging conversation about
coming to terms with what whiteness
has meant and what whiteness continues
to mean in our country
right now yeah i agree it's a
challenging conversation and i just want
to be upfront it might be particularly
challenging because
um i identify as a black man and i'm
seen that way
um and i don't i don't know how you
identify i'd love to hear it but
certainly with the name like lopez
people likely identify you as latinx or
something similar um and it's often hard
to talk about white identity
and uh maybe even more challenging when
the people having the conversation and
again i'll
let you speak to your identification
when i don't identify as white
yeah i think that that's right and i
think it also goes well beyond that so i
identify as latino
um but i think that that part of the
part of one of the main attributes of
whiteness
is a sort of um um
a floating above a floating outside
of race um that somehow race is
something that people of color have but
not something that white people have
and then and and connected to that as a
sort of an innocence um
that white people are constituted as
full humans
not significantly shaped by race
and then connected to that um is what's
been termed white fragility
a sense of anxiety a sense of
um being under attack when the
conversation
turns to race and it's really important
to acknowledge it
and then also to try and get beyond it
to try and say listen
we are a country that has been
structured in terms of race
going back 400 years and we're not going
to deal with it
unless we can have thoughtful considered
measured conversations about race and
these conversations
they can be challenging but they they
need they are not they
they are not necessarily attacks they
need not be construed as
attacks really the only way to get get
through this
is to to really open ourselves up
to conversations that make us
uncomfortable
that may be unfamiliar but which
really all of us as human beings are
capable of
thinking through and processing and
internalizing and
it's right so race is something that we
can make progress on
yeah i'd like to think about the
distinction between whiteness as an
as an idea and white people as a
category um
in part i think this is again as a black
man from the outside and someone who
studied this and
talks to people about it i think maybe
part of the problem is
um white people that category not the
concept of whiteness
doesn't it's not clear what the positive
content of that category is
right so as a black man there's a sense
of pride in terms of having overcome
the community that belongs to overcoming
certain struggles or the production of
culture that's attributed to that
category what is exactly what's the
concept the positive content of the
white category because without that yeah
it seems reasonable that people would
feel attacked if all that is
all it means to be white is to be racist
or to be perceived as such
yeah i mean there's there's there's so
much there so
let's start with the category um
and let me start in a personal way so my
dad's white my mother is from el
salvador
i was born and raised in hawaii
until i went to st louis missouri for
college
i didn't really have a racial identity
that was cognizable in the way in which
race is constructed on
what we call the mainland right so i i
come to the mainland
and um i'm i'm at an elite university
um i'm you know a little bit browner
than most people
um there's some double takes people
don't know what to do
with me uh but to the extent that i'm
articulate you know i i'm competitive at
this
at this elite school uh my english is
unaccented
um people begin to accept me and i later
come to this is sort of the race theory
part i later come to say
i was extended a presumption of
whiteness i was extended a presumption
of being a white person
i was i was offered honorary whiteness
but that didn't protect me from police
stops
in st louis in baltimore in boston
in in virginia
um you know that didn't protect me from
some sorts of harassment from a few of
my fellow students
and so you know really what i came to
understand is
these categories uh white people
black people latinos they're not
rooted in nature they're fixed by social
practices and this
and the social practices themselves are
malleable
themselves are continuing to shift
underfoot so
the first book i write is white by law
which is
tracing legal definitions of whiteness
over a couple of hundred years right you
can't write a book like that and think
well let's focus on the category the
category is always shifting or another
way to think about this
latino as a race the idea that latinos
as a race has really solidified
over the last four years in part because
there's been so much racism
aimed at latinos and i don't mean to say
everybody in the audience has to nod
their heads and say yes latinos are a
race
i mean to say the idea of thinking of
latinos as a race is much more
prevalent now because of changing social
practices right so
so so one point here is let's think
about social practices
another point then is okay so what is
whiteness as a set of social practices
whiteness is a set of ideas that
you know we would recognize as as racist
a set of ideas that say
that says being within the white
category
and also being lighter even if you're
not within the white
category or frankly sometimes even
within the light in the within the white
category
the lighter whites right the white
anglo-saxon protestant desert as opposed
to
the southern italian being lighter is
better
being whiter is better better in what
sorts of ways
innocent law-abiding rational capable
of self-government hard-working decent
committed to fair play in contrast and
of course
there must be a contrast because these
are relational concepts
being black or being darker is inferior
and in what sorts of ways being more
brutish less intelligent
um uh thieving lazy
um incapable of self-control and
therefore incapable of self-government
all of these sorts of stereotypes and
now
these aren't just ideas i mean they are
right they're racist ideas but
they are the racist ideas on which a lot
of the economy a lot of the political
infrastructure a lot of the culture a
lot of the material
infrastructure of our society that the
concrete of our society has been
poured in keeping with these ideas
and it's important that these ideas have
material manifestations because it's the
very materiality of race
that keeps reinforcing the notion that
these ideas
are true and so just a you know the the
sort of uh
east palo alto to palo alto kind of you
know
um movement
as you walk from a neighborhood that has
a long history of segregation
and disinvestment and that is primarily
occupied by working class or by poor
brown and black people into a
neighborhood
marked by by resources
by by segregation that favored rights
um by high levels of education by very
high levels of income
it takes an awful lot to look at that
and say oh these are social
practices that created that rather than
to move through those environments
and at a subconscious level have your
mind
reaffirm the racist beliefs that say
white is better light is better black
and
and and light and and dark
is inferior and dangerous yeah so that's
i mean that's all over the country right
so as you
they're the communities that sit not too
far apart where there's a huge
differences in how those communities are
are living right so you it's a
across the proverbial tracks right um
but i still wonder if you so the way
you're describing if i understand
correctly you could
eliminate whiteness as an idea as a
sense that
white is better white is innocent white
is smarter you could eliminate that
without eliminating obviously white
people is that
is that true and if so what's left
that's true but you're i'm so glad you
came back to this question because it's
such an enormously important question
you know so so um uh
here's what we're doing among many
progressives among many progressives
we're saying um
there really isn't anything positive
about whiteness
and white people need to repudiate
whiteness as a set of ideas
and they need to grapple with their own
guilt
for the tremendous damage done to our
society through endorsements of racial
hierarchy through practices of racial
hierarchy
they need to recognize and dismantle the
privileges that have helped them
that is being white in the sort of
um uh progressive mindset these days
being white is a major liability it's
it's it's a problem
you you need to do something about it
right and it's it's
guilt and privilege and repudiating
whiteness
and that's great as as an ideal
and i applaud those whites who are able
to do it
but we should also be clear that's very
very few people very very few people
are able to look at their identity
look at it critically gain some critical
distance from it
retain a sense of self and yet at the
same time
remake how they position themselves in
society and how they
see um what it is that they've earned as
opposed to what it is that's
illegitimate about how they've been
advantaged
that can recalibrate their relationships
with others
it's extraordinarily difficult and and i
and i say all of this
let me also add um as the as the code
to my first book white by law this was
my basic advice my basic advice was hey
white people you should really work
against whiteness because there's
nothing good about it
right and and i just think it's a
tremendous mistake
it's a tremendous mistake to do that and
i think that
the the way we see that is partly
pragmatic
it's advice that people can't follow and
it's advice
that actually makes sure that
whites remain defensive about whiteness
right because it if if what they're
facing is a prospect of having to
remake their sense of self many whites
will instead react
by saying i don't think there's a
problem here you're attacking me
you're the problem right so we actually
the conflict remains
pardon me if ins
so is pragmatic but but but it's also
analytic
that sort of an approach understands
people's
orientation towards race as being sort
of
um uh simple and unified
that that people react to race in one
way the people are
committed to white dominance for example
or
have no commitment to white dominance
whatsoever and and in this sort of a
an understanding of race people within
the white category
are the problem people outside the white
category are
immune to the problem but analytically
that's not right
within the white category you have
people who
simultaneously
draw on often unconsciously the racism
associated with whiteness and who are
also
consciously really striving to be good
decent racially egalitarian people
all right so you've got a lot of whites
who are
and a lot of us right i really i talk
about our split minds on race
a lot of us are simultaneously
drawing on deeply internalized racism
and trying
really hard not to be racist to be
racially egalitarian to build
cross-racial solidarity
that's true of very many whites and at
the same time
among people who fall in the people of
category people of color category
you see significant segments of that
population
drawing heavily on norms of whiteness
and it may not be a claim of
i'm white but it's certainly a claim
that says
lighter is better um people like me
are hardworking hard-working innocent
deserving people like my neighbors who
are darker or more recent immigrants
or you know can be prejudiced against
different groups there's certainly a lot
of anti-black prejudice and
many communities of color latinos
right that's whiteness operating there
too
and yet we we're not so quick to condemn
those folks to saying well you only have
one orientation towards race right
almost all of us have split minds on it
where we're simultaneously
influenced by the status hierarchy of
whiteness
seeking what advantage we can for
ourselves in terms of whiteness
even if we're not white people and at
the same time
understanding embracing
a value system that says we're all human
we all deserve dignity
we we need to build connections with
each other as human beings we're all
wrestling with that yeah so here let's
go down to brass tacks your white parent
given what you just said i i i
appreciate the understanding of
the difficulty in in managing that
identity in the current environment
right the
the pull towards taking the advantages
associated with it even though morally
you may be
you are really invested and motivated in
being a good person that really embraces
uh a just society if you're that person
what do you tell your kids about being
white
i think so so first and foremost
you tell your kids about being white and
even that
you have to understand that's radical
advice because
for among many liberal whites the norm
is color blindness the norm is
the best way to not be racist is to
never talk about race
but we know from practice from social
psychological research
not talking about race with your kids
simply ensures that your kids
absorb racist lessons from society at
large so number one
talk to your kids about race number two
you know i guess let me back up for for
just a second
race is one of those weird subjects
where
because people live it every day people
think it's pretty obvious and that they
know it and that they're familiar with
it
and and i and i sometimes say well look
you spend money every day
but that doesn't you know but you don't
say well therefore i'm an economist
therefore i got the economy i understand
it macroeconomics
yeah no problem because i have cash and
credit cards
that's not how that works if you wanted
to understand the economy
if you wanted to talk to your kids about
the economy
you'd do some reading you'd do some
research you'd watch some documentaries
you'd say
oh i shouldn't talk to my kids out of
ignorance i really need to educate
myself this is a field that requires
study
race is a field that requires study yes
we all
are living it but the very terms on
which we're living it
is full of lies and misinformation and
racist myths
so i think if if a white parent says to
me hey how should i talk to my kid about
race
or about whiteness the first thing i'd
say is i'm
really really glad that that's your
project before you start talking
do some learning um and whether that's
you know reading some of the history or
watching some of the documentaries or
just
practicing with other adults saying hey
what does whiteness mean
and what has it meant in my life
but you know let me not completely evade
the question i think
the most important thing to communicate
is we're all in this together
we're situated differently in our
society race is real
but race is not fixed and it's not
natural
it's human made and that and this is one
of the things that that i think
martin luther king stressed that i think
it was
one of his most important contributions
is every time that he said something
critical about
society almost every time he would
continue and say
but if we've done this we can undo it
and i think that's the most important
message that parents can communicate to
their kids
this isn't fixed this is we've done this
our society's done this
we're implicating it we can't step
outside of it
but we can fix it okay
that's that's close to a true answer for
what they should say to their kids i'll
take it
uh let me pivot a little bit and move to
politics i know this is something that's
really important to you right now
um and you talk quite a bit about in the
dog whistle politics in your
um one of your recent books um i'm
curious how we think about that
right now so you you know that um
whiteness of race has a greater force
when it's not consciously acknowledged
that's one of the points you made in the
book
um and so i have a few questions there
one
do you do you think that's changing do
you still think that's true but for my
perception it looks like um
president trump donald trump the
outgoing president uh was using a
bullhorn not a
dog whistle so i'm curious what do you
think now about that
importance of kind of not acknowledging
race
so so let me say yes it's changing
changing in a very dangerous direction
um but also let's let's let's be clear
about
the the sort of very few people that
refers to
so if you ask people whether they're
sympathetic to the ku klux klan or the
white supremacy
you get answers in the range of two to
four percent of the population saying
yeah i'm sympathetic
if you ask trump supporters that number
tends to double
but now we're we're talking four to
eight percent right so
i i think it's very very important to be
clear
that the strategy that donald trump is
using is a strategy that's 50 years old
that really starts after the civil
rights movement
that starts in response to the civil
rights movement and there's two aspects
of the civil rights movement that are
relevant
one the increasing anxiety
and backlash among whites in the face of
demands for racial equality
and two the broad acceptance among
whites that racial equality is the moral
position
and racism the immoral one and
what happens is and again this is the
split minds on race
you get politicians who begin to use
language that
simultaneously triggers racist fears
but is designed to allow people to
believe that they are real
reacting not to racism but to hire
principal
so a conversation in the 1960s the
conversation was states rights
states rights pretended that the issue
was federal state relations
when in fact it was the federal
government ordering southern states to
end their practices of racial oppression
and racial humiliation
or forced busing or law and order
or welfare queens those are all dog
whistles and their dog whistles
i notice this goes back to like what
whiteness means
their dog whistles connected to racist
stereotypes about who whites are
and about who people of color are but
they're expressed
in these terms that allow people to say
hey this isn't about white and black no
one used a racial epithet
the only question here is how do i feel
about welfare cheats how do i feel about
criminals how do i feel about putting my
children on a bus
right now think about donald trump's
language
trump was very careful never to use a
racial epithet
trump was very careful to you know he he
once said
you know i could walk down the middle of
fifth avenue and shoot somebody and
people would still love me true or
largely true
what he couldn't do is stand in the
middle of fifth avenue and start using
racial epithets
start saying the s word at the n word
start saying the s
word because then you know his eight
percent
they would have loved it maybe right the
david dukes and his fans
but although even david duke doesn't say
he's a white supremacist he says he's
simply fighting for the rights of euro
americans right
again that sort of evasion donald trump
was very careful to use language that
allowed his
followers to say this is just common
sense this isn't racism
and and and i want to be clear i'm not
just saying this on a sort of um
hey professor of racism anecdote that's
my impression
uh in 2017 after trump was uh
inaugurated and again in the in the
summer of 2020
i ran major national focus groups
and um poll testing and i tested a
version of trump's message
a message that talked about sanctuary
cities and countries overrun with gangs
and the need to fully fund our police
um to protect ourselves against people
who refuse to follow our laws we need to
take care of our own people first
the sort of language that many of us on
the sort of progressive political side
say
hey that's that's a bullhorn
that wasn't recognized as a as as racism
um in fact it was recognized as
convincing
not just by a majority of republicans
but by a majority of democrats
a majority of union households and union
households
that's important because they're doing a
lot of work to educate their membership
about how to understand political
messaging so majority of democrats
majority of union households
majority of latinos a majority of
african americans
found that message convincing it it
can't be
that that message has come is out and
out is a bull horn of white racism
and a majority of african americans are
saying yeah i agree
we need to fully fund our police to
protect against people who refuse to
follow our laws
right this this is
racial demagoguery in code
that's that that's that's why we're
calling it dog was a politics and now
it's gotten more extreme and the more
extreme
versions of it are are fueling
um pushing people towards the explicit
version
towards the out and out i'm a white
nationalist
whites are under attack we've got to
fight back
um but again and i mean this is really
remarkable
even people who are for example members
of the proud boys
right so so avowed um
um an avowed commitments to violence
to defend against a perceived threat to
white people
from non-white people even many members
of the white boys
are themselves either latinos or asian
americans
right who who really do believe that
there's a racial conflict coming
but also feel like they can be part of
this
expansive white team right so these are
this is very
it's an enormous mistake to simplify
this and to say
donald trump appealed the bigots donald
trump spoke in the language of bigots
and the people who voted for donald
trump
are bigots and the and to and to then
divide the country between
the bigots and all the rest of us it
misses
the sort of complicacy the humanity of
many trump voters
and it misses the way in which many of
us
not just regular folks certainly the
pundit class and a lot of the democratic
elite
are themselves implicated in thinking
that these sorts of dog whistles are
reasonable in common sense
they think that themselves and that's an
enormous challenge for us on the left
yeah i mean i the way i read it is that
racism has been
either defined down or defined up out of
existence
right so people want to see themselves
as good people obviously
and what we've done is allowed the being
someone charging with racism that is a
bigger issue than engaging in behaviors
that seem racist which brings me to the
something else i wanted to want to go
back to
i think the inherent innocence
associated with whiteness allows people
to engage in what is racist behavior and
not
see it as racist so if that's what we
mean by it's a dog whistle because they
don't
acknowledge it as as racist then i'm
really worried because i don't know
what would have to happen for it to be
acknowledged as racist
right and and and um so i guess i just
wanted to make that point and
maybe pivot a little bit because i want
to talk about
um the insurrection the mob the riot
whatever
however we want to define it maybe it's
all those all the above
at the capitol and tie that to the idea
of inherent innocence
so what was it was amazing um that
people one
were allowed to walk out after engaging
those behaviors we can talk about that
but also
um i'm curious what you thought about
what you make of people's that were
engaged their sense of self
as they engaged in those behaviors they
didn't think of themselves like we
are rioters we are insurrectionists
they they saw themselves as doing
the right thing and i'm curious in your
mind is that tied to this idea of
whiteness and innocence being
joined together it is but i want to add
another layer to this because
part of the way we've been talking about
ray so far
is in a way that that treats people's
orientation
towards egalitarianism and racial
hierarchy
is pretty static and i want to add an
element of motivation
i i want to say people are trying to
think through
very often unconsciously a sort about
what's good for me what's good for my
family
sort of analysis of egalitarianism
and and racial oppression racial
hierarchy and
and this can be really quite dramatic so
if you want to understand the protesters
you have to understand
the larger story being told to them by
the right-wing propaganda machine and
i'll just
the right-wing propaganda machine
includes the gop
um fox and social media a lot of think
tanks white evangelical churches
there's a pretty coherent story that's
being told and it's a story that
says fear and resent people of color
but hate liberal government and hate
liberals because
they refuse to control those dangerous
people of color and instead
coddle them with government giveaways
turn away from activist government
support the free market
build walls you're on your own go buy a
gun
that's the basic narrative and we can
come back and talk
about it i think it's very important to
notice it's a racial narrative
tied to a sort of a political economic
position
liberal government is the enemy okay but
if that's the
story that you've internalized then
what you've come to believe is the way
to take care of your
children and and i want to put it in
those value terms right because this is
people trying to take care of their
children
the way to take care of your children is
fight for the rights of decent
hard-working innocent people
that are being stolen by angry
minorities
and their white enablers and their
liberal democratic enablers but that's
the story that you're being fed all the
time
it's very important that people are
thinking through
race and racial oppression racial
hierarchy but also racial egalitarianism
in a
through a lens of what takes care of my
children
because that opens up the possibility
that we can have a very different
conversation
and this is this is what i was working
on with all those focus groups and all
that national pull testing
to tell a different story to tell a
story that says
you're not threatened by people of color
the real danger in your life does not
come
from your neighbors or people of a
different religion or sexual
orientation or different gender at all
at the sort of
culture where politics lies the real
danger in the lives of all of us
comes from demagogic politicians
who promote division and acrimony
but whose main goal is to serve the
interests
of billionaires like themselves and
their billionaire buddies
in other words the main enemy are the
very few who are trying to rig
our economy our politics our government
for themselves
and their main strategy is to promote
the vision
therefore the racially egalitarian norms
that you already hold
rather than those exposing you to
dangerous and undeserving people
those egalitarian norms are actually the
pragmatic way in which you take care of
your children
because by building cross-racial
solidarity
and only by building cross-racial
can you achieve sufficient political
power to bring government back on the
side of
all working families rather than on the
side of these narrow elites
pushing divide and conquer politics
that's a compelling argument but i'm
going to push back against it
so i think you're focusing on material
outcomes which i think is when people
think about pocketbook issues yes
so your situation will be better off
that you know the stagnation and
right and wages all those things are a
function you could argue of
the economic elites controlling the
political system
and possibly using race as a means to do
that
but it's also the case that there are
benefits associated with whiteness that
aren't just
economic interests right the feeling of
yourself
as being above or better than
the self perception that's tied to being
a part of that
that powerful beautiful smart group
has value so when you talk just in terms
of pocketbook issues do you think that
that's enough are people that are people
going to be willing to give up those
other person you know non-material
interests
yes it's such a such a great question so
let me back up and say the approach that
i'm
that i'm advocating is not novel it's
not
original this is martin luther king's
poor people's campaign right the the
idea
that we can't achieve racial justice
except through a cross-racial movement
that also addresses economic inequality
and frankly also
addresses militarism it's also the ideal
that animated the fusion movement
at the at right after the civil war that
said
newly emancipated people had to find and
build
common cause with um
poor whites who had supported slavery
but in fact remained heavily exploited
by the planter class and that they had
to find common cause
um and i want to emphasize that because
i want to i want to say look
this is in some ways the the the sort of
the heart of of of of democracy
that we can build a society in which we
take care of each other but
only when we understand our fates are
linked and now we get to your question
okay but is material interest enough
and another version of your question
might be well it didn't work
in the 1860s and it didn't work in the
1960s
why might it work now so let me come
back to this idea of material interest
one thing i want to be clear about is
you're right there aren't just material
interests of whiteness there are also
psychological
interests associated with it of feeling
like this is your country that your
ancestors built it that you belong that
you're innocent and hard-working that
you're
due esteem and respect when you interact
with
government officials especially the
police right um
and and um w.b du bois when he was
talking about reconstruction
talked about these these material wages
of whiteness these psychological wages
of whiteness and
david roediger as a scholar of race
writing about dubois gave us that phrase
the wages of whiteness
i'm talking about both the material and
the psychological wages of whiteness and
i think it's very important to look at
how
both of those differ between now and
let's say
1968. so if you think about
1968 the material wages of whiteness
were incredibly high
protected jobs in protected jobs
protected membership in unions
protected access to to schools to
different employers to better
neighborhoods
and at the same time the psychological
wages of whiteness
were very very high we were just
emerging
we're just moving past expressed
commitments to white supremacy to the
superiority of whites
to all we were just coming to understand
that
stereotypes about african-americans and
latinos and asian-americans
were racist and ugly stereotypes and not
statements of fact
fast forward to 2021 the material wages
of whiteness
50 years of rule by the rich in which
wealth from the great middle in america
has been siphoned upwards to the
economic stratosphere
precisely by people like donald trump
the material wages of whiteness today
think about what just happened in terms
of the pandemic and a federal government
that was
unwilling to commit to protecting
working families
and the psychological wages of whiteness
those two
have fallen and even reversed and part
of it and a lot of credit actually goes
to
not just decades of civil rights
activism and graduate transformation and
entertainment and sports
but the obamas as a family in the white
house
really undercut the idea that one should
construct one's identity around
pride and whiteness and then to donald
trump
donald trump today is the public face of
what white pride looks like
and it's an ugly distorted angry
spiteful face and a lot of whites are
looking at that and saying
i don't see any benefit to myself in
constructing myself
as white right so why now
it is not certain at all but i think for
the first time in the 400 year history
of our society
we really do have an opportunity to
convince
a majority a super majority
of our population within the white
category
and beyond the white category that
whiteness is a threat to the lives of
their own children
and that the best route forward is
purposefully building cross-racial
solidarity
so that we can actually build a better
life for our own families
as well as for the families of our
neighbors that's a possibility now
precisely because of these big and very
important changes
in the wages of whiteness um that's a
good segue because you pointed out this
is an opportunity for a significant
change i'm not sure it's the first
opportunity but i will agree that it's
another opportunity for this country
um and so given that there are a number
of people that are listening
right now what's the most important
thing an individual can do
to advance racial justice right now you
have someone asked you what should i do
what would you tell them
i think i would tell them wrestle with
this
idea that racism isn't
primarily a conflict of whites versus
people of color racism isn't
primarily a hierarchy of whites over
non-whites
racism is primarily a weapon of the rich
in which the powerful few intentionally
promote a hierarchy of whites over
non-whites
intentionally promote conflict between
racial groups
wrestle with that idea because the
possibilities that flow from
that idea are truly radical and indeed
truly
emancipatory because it helps us
get out of the idea that we are locked
into a conflict in terms of
racial groups and that we all have to
pick a racial team defend the interests
of
that racial group and instead makes
clear we really are all in this together
and it's not that racial hierarchy
isn't there it's not that white racism
isn't fair it's not that white privilege
isn't a thing that people have to deal
with
all of that is right but it's also
correct
it's also imperative that the real
people who gain from racial conflict
are those who stand behind it who
encourage it
who fund it who stoke it who fuel it
and it's the donald trumps it's the sean
hannities and the tucker carlson's
millionaire shills for billionaires
who shield by promoting racism and
racial conflict if we can get our heads
around that idea
we can recommit to the democratic ideal
of a pluribus unum
that a democracy works when we make
one out of many not one in the sense of
we're all the same
but one in the sense of we're all
committed to taking care of each other
through the processes of shared
governance
and making sure that government works
for all of us
and not just for the powerful few
great well um that is a great place to
end and actually i want to
um supplement that with a final quote
from martin luther king jr
after talking about a number of the ills
of the country he had this to say
this does not imply that all white
americans are racist far from it
many white people have through a deep
moral compulsion
fought long and hard for racial justice
nor does it mean that america has made
no progress
in her attempt to cure the body politic
of the disease of racism
or that the dogma of racism has not been
considerably modified
in recent years however for the good of
america
it is necessary to refute the idea that
the dominant ideology in our country
even today
is freedom inequality while racism was
just an occasional departure from the
norm on the part of the few bigoted
extremists
end quote i'd like to say that i i'd
like to take from that that
we all have a a moral imperative to
think about the country we're part of
and how we all participate in it and how
we can
work to make it a more just place i
appreciate
ian you're coming on and talking to us
about this it's been
really interesting and enlightening
thanks so much for your time
thank you brian i really appreciate the
invitation and the conversation
great and thanks everyone for joining